I welcome to this video playing we won
we won from the u.s. plate before for a
change whoops for an opening in Sicilian
and we got the night off hmm let's play
this age 39 setting up a quick g-form I
really hope that he doesn't know which
head to well because um well my
knowledge is also very limited hmm
Queenie tool which would be three
something like that problem going for
long castles you can also go for short
it's not out of the question
hmm yeah why not
getting some space hmm Queenie to
yeah I can also think about short castle
in g 5a five stores very quick okay
let's do that maybe it's just quicker to
Castle short I don't need to play Queen
castles probably King be one and so on
maybe this is just a bit quicker yeah we
can take it with the Queen v5 Queen d2
this should be quiet game you okay
bishop f 6m yellow not sure should I
spend the move on a form
okay let's do that first hard to play
without it anyway intending f6 hmm how
long there is a reason why I really play
this kind of position in tournament
chess for black simply I simply get get
scared too much it looks it just looks
scary to me okay if I take here 95 takes
Queen takes King h8 I take a year and
i'm not sure Mike Wiener says little my
FF I don't have many squares for the
queen is what I'm trying to say but
still yeah I think it seems to work
Knight b6 I can take with the check
interm it's a that's there's a pin on
the rook takes Queen takes King h8 queen
a eight I'm threatening 25 returning so
it probably needs to play Knight b6
Bishop takes Queen 2x checking edge one
and then on the ship somewhere take on
yet Bishop d7 have Queen define so I
want an exchange and I'm also wondering
what the heck is he doing that do you
really you you need to take Jack yes but
now that I look at this position I
wonder I wonder if there's something
else it's like Queen f7 no that's not a
big monsters okay take him
yeah it's a bit greedy to take what I
mean clay 95 with the intention now of
course I'm a mistake and no other you
think Knight b6 is the only move either
otherwise i play clean d5 and just
returned you know okay I have no choice
need to take check and now we get to
exactly the position that I kept
calculated before yes probably needs to
to do that 25m I what I must make sure
that I'm not losing the Queen okay the
most powerful move now is certainly rook
f6 but is it also a good move Queen f7
done no yes he can easily cover it okay
so let's just play with them this
exchange up should be six coming maybe
no one can just take it okay maybe said
this little trip okay sometimes
sometimes those little trip Sarlacc
resigned yeah it could have played
Bishop d7 I mean it's it's an exchange
and probably a white should win but it's
not it's not so easy because this is
such a strong piece and the dark squares
a week he can really try to defend this
position but that I think somewhere here
there was something wrong I mean he may
be rookie I don't know I don't know this
type of position always scares me it's
black with all this stuff coming maybe
just Bishop d7 the computer so
completely unimpressed yeah it wants to
and defend like this and now grab the
graph the pawn like that and says equal
quite funny yell hard too hard to say
maybe this is a play will move on play
will set up it's certainly interesting
yeah but the way it it went I think and
white really gets get a th it's it's not
so easy to win but it should be it
should be better for white alright
thanks for watching